[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURA KIESEL: I have what I guess is called invisible illness,
so I don't look sick.
I've had this problem, even when I had my endometriosis was really bad.
And I was getting--
I was having a lot of gastrointestinal issues.
I was losing weight.
I remember going to my--
this was when I was in college-- going to the doctors there,
and them just not believing I was sick.
They accused me of being bulimic.
They were like, you probably just don't want to eat.
And I was like, no, I'm sick to my stomach.
I don't know what's wrong.
I'm in pain all the time.
But they were just like, you don't look sick.
Look at how healthy your hair is.
No one who is in pain could have hair as nice as you.
I've been told that by doctors.
And I've had similar things not as egregious as that as I've gotten older,
words like, well, you can walk.
And you're not in a wheelchair.
And you have nice teeth, or you have nice hair.
Or you'e too young to have back problems.
I've had one doctor say, thin people don't have the back problems
you seem to be having.
And it's like, well, I have those back problems.
So you see my MRI.
You see I have disc issues.
So there's a lot of-- there's new advocacy around this idea of just
because you can't plainly see that a person is in pain
or is disabled that doesn't mean they don't have illness or disability.
But it's still very hard, and I sometimes feel like even with doctors
I have to really argue with them.
Like, I'm in a lot of pain.
And even though I'm standing here, and I'm not crying,
and I'm not in a wheelchair,
I'm in pain.
And then there's the 1 through 10 thing--
tell me how much pain you're in.
And it's really hard if you live with chronic pain as your daily reality,
because it&#39;s harder to gauge.
Because it's like, well, this is my daily reality.
You kind of adapt a little to the pain.
And it's like, well, if this pain was brand new,
I'd be in the emergency room.
But I live like this every day.
So I guess it's for me now a 5, but when I first started getting it,
it was an 8 or a 9.
But it's still bad.
It's just I've lived with it every day.
And I know now I'm not dying from it.
But so those 1 to 10 things can be really deceiving,
because you don't even know what to tell doctors when it's something
you live with every single day.